not suitable for children or those who
are easily disturbed something tells me
this literature club ain't gonna be too
good for my health
welcome to literature club it's a
pleasure meeting you
you got purple hair you're probably evil
thank you for all standing in order of
tallest to shortest and also biggest
boobs to smallest boob I appreciate that
that's really welcome you got the family
and dooblydoo email a [__] okay okay
everyone shut your traps gang dog Bing
bong time to read your bombs here Monica
does decree that it's time Oh what the
hell wait whoa without that music
doesn't a hot cup of tea and help you
enjoy a good book I don't trust you URI
that's good enough for me what about you
URI yo D she's still sulking
she's dead inside just like everybody
else is gonna be dead on the outside I
wrote butthole on one just in case
someone's favorite word is butthole you
never know
aardvark for people who enjoy the
beginning of the dictionary
you know Oh markiplier for people that
don't want a cupcake
anyway I saved I'm gonna go with Monica
I know say or E's probably needs to be
by her side right now but where's this I
flipped a series poem it's one that I
haven't read before oh she's my mind
sorry say Ori
wake up dummy there's no response I
gently open the door
oh I don't like this you've unlocked a
special poem would you like to read it
sure yeah stare at the doctor I don't
trust this I'm sharing it the dot don't
you don't you don't you [__] dare
jump there mate don't do it
oh I love you Oh give take it I can't
wait any longer
hurry read it Oh urine and blood I'm
pretty sure this is urine and blood all
right bye
oh wow do I like it no I don't like that
at all have a chat okay
the maybe I should know click now one
disaster contamination
that's [__] it's [__] it's
pulsating your [__] oh this is
[__] [__] [__] [__]
[__] [__] up beer look that
they'll get okie-dokie [__] baby nope
but play a little upper library there
but nature love it up a new boat
together love a double-dip mode destiny
oh [__] that's Bob Babbitt childhood hey
I think I got it